hello everyone I will honored welcome to
my channel and today I'm playing the
first hour beyond the prologue of scorn
I was able to play the prologue a few
weeks ago maybe even a month ago at this
point
um as part of a preview build and I have
paused it exactly where the preview
build ended like basically on that exact
frame
so we're now going to play like the
first hour of the game beyond that point
see how much more the game opens up
um I felt like it was worth doing a
second hour of of gameplay where usually
I don't do that on this channel I
usually do first hour Impressions
because I still have a lot of questions
about the game how much comment is it
going to be is it going to be as puzzle
focused as the first hour but for anyone
who missed that first hour I'll leave a
link in the description to where you can
check that out and I can confirm that
the full build of the game is the same
the preview has not actually changed at
all so let's pick it up from where we
left off
this exact
black screen
and I'm uh now playing on Xbox I was
playing on PC previously and had some
issues with my ultra wide monitor
compatibility so this is a Xbox
okay
I just got like eaten by the ground kind
of
so I guess this is me breaking out of
that it's like a bunch of goop
still the same person even
I think that's an umbilical cord is just
somebody being reborn
I feel like we saw this shot in the
trailers
we did
for sure oh God
it's so gross but in such like an
interesting way
new environment different color scheme
clear that this is the path it wants me
to take but
I don't know if this game has optional
content I will say for my Xbox
Achievement Hunters out there okay yeah
it doesn't
um it's pretty linear
um there are I believe 12 achievements
and it looks like
let me just show you
I have two
yeah there are 12. or a thousand cheese
so
I like the sound design
not sure if it's me making that
scattering sound or something else it's
probably me right
I'm not being followed I think it's my
own footsteps well
I think it might want me to go to the
right
oh
very curious about the law of this place
and so far we've had no dialogue
whatsoever
not even any like diary entries and
nothing so I wonder
if we're ever gonna find anything out
or if it's uh
gonna be on audiences to make their best
guesses
seems wrong
not this way
the structure over here
get over that
no okay
do you have to find some way forward
[Music]
should go check this out I guess this is
definitely a little bit aimless but
feels alien for sure
is this making the noise I wonder
you like probably gotta get in here
somehow
it's the only structure in sight
[Music]
[Music]
or is this where I came from
who knows so many Mysteries
wow
and I'm finding it interesting that I
expected this game to be a horror game
but thus far
I would not say I've been scared at all
interested grossed out definitely which
I kind of like
um but not scared
I bet you I've just caused myself for a
jump scare that's always
typical
oh this does look like the building I
just came from
it is I think because
I opened those I mean I guess this just
place just
similar architecture and then that's
like the goop that swallowed me so maybe
the prologue was somebody else
who's now dead and now I am a different
alien
is it like a hive mind is that what
you're trying to tell me
okay now I'm a little bit scared
foreign
I hate that actually
okay
oh that's so Xenomorph
should I just go see what happens to
like rid myself of the fear
I don't wanna
I don't see any other way to go though
um
all right mate let's [ __ ] get it over
with
oh we ran away
again alien isolation 2 finally all
right
yikes or maybe he's a friend friends
could be scuttery
doubt it to be honest about it
don't think so it's possible
what are you
can't interact with it yet
okay
no not you either right okay
I will be back for you later oh that's
here we go
that is one thing that I found on a kind
of track without you though no
um is it you can definitely miss uh I
found it with the prologue you
definitely missed some of those
interact with the bulls because the UI
is so limited which to be honest I like
I can just see a lot of people getting
stuck
because they missed that they could
interact with something
I probably need to find another one of a
okay
one of the arm things
put the doodad on my hand please
so I can operate machinery
if you will
hello sir
hands do dad confirmed or is this a gun
[Music]
a key
foreign
was supposed to wait until the
blank I think
oh that makes sense it would be the top
okay
uh a gun
no clue thanks though appreciate that
[Music]
I mean do I even still have whatever
that was
no
okay
go back to the other room maybe
see if there's anything else I can do
that now
there's not anything here okay
keep moving
how about now
hey
I don't trust any of this actually but
thank you
hey
maybe I just needed to do that faster
is that wall gonna come back come back
it's kind of cute
okay now I leave this and I run over
Go Baby Go baby go
no okay
elevator okay
see if there's anything else fast
up we go
hey bud
I think
God go that way
I decide
only one puff okay
to call the elevator probably
did you move yeah okay
looks like a dead end it is definitely
very linear
and like it's almost like got a point
and click
approach to puzzles where
the solution is just you trying stuff
till it works but it doesn't tell you
what the solution is which I kind of
miss in a way
it makes you feel like creative in a
very unique way okay
foreign
that's kind of neat
okay synth all right hello
hey bud
I mean listen if he died there maybe we
shouldn't
we can't okay
hello there
okay
I'm not sure if it's moving in equal
part no it's not
just wait for it
okay it does end up on this one for sure
like every second rotation
one ends up
over here
oh no not quite
there
nope
this time
here
at the top
[Music]
I think I'm just like
adding more
notches to a key
why are the looks of things is he gonna
work in here now probably not
it's probably where I need to get back
to though so we're going to connect the
bridge
in another Direction
um hard to say which way I've already
come from probably not this way
but maybe I would be able to get through
here because of the bodies
[Music]
that is quite nasty that is oh
okay uh never mind sorry to disturb you
all as you were
as you were
this one
which one did I come from I think
probably this one is the one I should be
going for I think I came from that other
side
but my sense of direction is oh terrible
okay cool
hope he's friendly sure hope he's
friendly
not Interactive
okay
looks like a hot
nothing in here
no
just a sort of set piece
okay
you God
the the man who is responsible for the
uh art
[Applause]
friendly
well I feel like that had to be scripted
right
oh my God you're really going for it
okay
wow definitely scripted okay combat
um Geiger is the the
the artist responsible for the style of
alien and um clearly inspired this game
as well
and it's just very clear to me
um
how like
phallic everything is which I think was
actually part of their intention
um like the xenomorph is supposed to be
like a very sexual horror
thing
oh hang on I gotta go back through where
the fans were which I think was still
this way wasn't it
flip myself around
why were the fans actually a spinning
for them
here
where the [ __ ] were they spinning
I saw them from up here
I I honestly I get lost in the most
basic in video games it's a real problem
just go down
oh here okay it's just like at the start
okay
it's probably gonna be combat soon by
the vibe
again I don't know oh is this that same
gun oh it is it doesn't actually shoot
bullets it just shoots like a little
prod
did I just go full circle no no no no no
no I didn't I didn't
the last key thing yeah okay
where do you land down here
foreign
probably one more
somehow
I should go down from here
downstairs can I get down there
I can but the path is blocked
noted okay
put that this way
uh no okay
okay
where is the spooky fella
I wonder
oh it's gonna give me that weird arm
thing back
whatever this alien species is that I am
uh controlling as it were
they are sturdy Gotta Give Them props
for that
um yeah we've already been through
some [ __ ]
and you are holding it together my guy
foreign
already done that
this is back at the first area question
mark
oh yeah wait I came back wayfall I don't
even remember where
things were from here
all right so I actually got super stuck
here and I asked a friend for help for
the interest of time
um because I just completely forgot
where everything was
and was like walking around in circles
for way too long uh I might even mess it
up this way around to be honest
so I did ask a friend for help
and they were like yeah you had the
right idea you just got to go to the
right place to do it
because uh a thing that I definitely
completely forgot about so not this way
get there
oh I think it's just upstairs how do I
get up
elevator
it's in here I think
um but it's definitely a thing in this
game where because everything I think I
said this earlier because everything
looks very similar
it is easy
to get
lost
um
I want to like have trouble
differentiating
what is what I'm trying to get to
it's like Santa
clinkets this way
from this way
all right yeah this way
I'm pretty sure it's there
foreign
keep going this way no okay that's what
I'm trying to clear
the
bodies
they're the only thing stopping you from
going on that path so is it this way
maybe
oh
because I've also now like gone to get
myself a drink and stuff
who knows man who knows
there is like a center console here it
is okay
this is the thing that I needed the arm
control for
and yeah I'm trying to clear the pathway
so I can get up here obviously got to
get rid of those bodies
oh
remove it
over here
beautiful
oh my gosh this game's so like torturous
hey that's enough that's enough man
leave them be
okay
we're gonna go back down
she's
this way
and go to the middle one
nice
alrighty
that's gonna be it I don't trust this
for a second
get the final piece of the key
okay
if you say so
oh interesting
thank you
maybe need to go one further
yeah okay
that should be the end of the key
awesome
anything else to do over here you
doesn't look like it that thing is I
feel like almost definitely going to
show back up
which one do I go to from here
the what
[Music]
okay
this is right isn't it uh no
yes okay I just have to go down
I do like the um
the whole level being like one puzzle
thing like I am a fan of
the idea of an entire level all just
feeding into one puzzle
do you think that's cool
all right
are you gonna stay now
no
that's where that went
okay
can this be moved now
no
I don't think so
oh it can
let's have a look first shall we
okay
it's cool design
um
that's probably not right probably
probably there
there yeah
try to look at it like it's an actual
key so I guess it's got to go the whole
way down
I first want to screw the whole way
um okay
you can definitely go the whole way this
way
okay this is interesting
um
that is gonna have to be like how do we
he's gonna go there
this one
you gotta go here
the last one's gotta go here
oh it's cool
and I'm doing this why
oh look at it
a little tenderly things
oh I hate that a lot why did we take it
okay
okay
uh
I am become God
oh this is an actual gun or is this the
same gun
because I know there are guns in this
game somewhere
hey bro we chill
didn't do anything
okay
well
that's gonna be a yikes for me uh where
do I go from here I wonder
I guess something else somewhere must be
open
this is all the same stuff this doll
yeah
this wasn't open before
you open now my friend
aha
that's interesting
okay
more of the same really
I thought that was a gun I guess it's
not
um
it's just like a a key of some sort
some sort of a key contraption
I suppose
surprise that's open
do the only way to go okay
it is for now
it's like he's got his own Clicker
all right
more elevators I wonder where the the
definitely not xenomorph went
is that it's screaming or does your
elevator just have a unique
deathly squeak
that's the look at it to be honest okay
of course whoop
what
you [ __ ] you what who did I do that
to myself
who even did that what the hell
The Vibes are bad
those little blood sex oh I hate that
thing oh God I hate it a lot
oh I don't want it back
oh
my God
it is a uniquely disgusting video game
and I and like I am impressed by it it
is making me feel things
that I wasn't there's nothing for me to
do here right I want to just double
check that yeah
oh is that a big version of what I have
no
no it isn't
it's also interesting
having me do stuff like that when I
picked up that thing I didn't know what
it would be used for and then I interact
with this machine because it's like the
only thing that happens when you
interact with the machine one thing I
really like about scone
um having played it is while playing it
with you right now is I do really like
that all of the things that you do are
actual interactions like an actual
animation a hand moving a lever being
pulled like it's all actually animated I
think that's really cool
um but I I wonder if it's an intentional
storytelling choice that the alien that
I am controlling
seems to know what the Contraptions do
because I definitely don't things are
just occurring from my perspective as a
player but I wonder if the
alien
is supposed to have memory of this stuff
uh which is a very difficult balance to
strike is having your players know less
than your playable character
but um it kind of works here
I'm just not sure if that was like
intentional or not
that's actually a very pretty
scene right there
something very like
oddly beautiful about this
hmm
you know why I keep wanting to go
everywhere like it's like I'm looking
for Collectibles of course I'm not
just keep wanting to check every path
what was it that just hugged me can we
revisit that for a second
what was that death hug I just got
hello
everybody
okay if you say so
to say it was like this tool right the
the little
garage clicker
I would not have known what that thing
did the alien I am playing as is aware
okay
I'm gonna go left first
okay
oh I guess I'm gonna have to upgrade
that lock
or the key I suppose
because that had two lights rather than
one I think
[Music]
another sort of pretty scene
oh until I realize they look like heads
I take it back it's not pretty at all
it's awful
no
no it's not pretty
oh
oh they look like children
horrific okay
oh there we go it's upgraded cool
that'll get me through that other door
the sounds too and they're all like so
spidery
oh
it is nasty
[Music]
I just looped all right
at least I can get through here I think
okay
hello
thank you
it's like I might
oh my God these crawling sounds are
killing me
yikes
oh
I did not think that would work
I was like cool there's my next puzzle
nope apparently not
all right
this is good sound design I am
disgusted also these really look like
dicks
oh no
oh no
I want nothing to do with you oh my good
side nope no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
oh they're everywhere
okay I guess it's combat time
I guess I need to reload
did I shoot it I'm not even really sure
um
I know I have to get upstairs but I
don't know how to and now there's things
chasing me
am I gonna move it again maybe
that could be it
no I do have to get up there
oh
it's not gonna let me across here though
is it no I do need to get it to where it
was
and then flip it again
be strange to undo what I just did I
figure
but I'm still not sure if I attacked
that thing or not
maybe I can't yet
um how do we think we get up
okay we move this one again I think
seems like it won't attack me if I'm on
the machine
cool
get up there
oh God
just passing through
don't mind me
just passing through
I have no beef with your kind
frankly I want absolutely nothing to do
with you
[Music]
that is a battle
for which I do not feel prepared okay
maybe
I remember seeing like a track in this
first room
that I'm thinking I might be able to
ride through there
you think it was in here
see there
um
that's moving
so I've got to figure out how to get
over there
might be another door I missed probably
already done that
that doesn't do anything just a light
oh this is the I didn't even realize
this is it
oh
I just had my
orientational room
cool okay
hello
sort of excited to be honest
again whose hands are those
are those my own hands am I doing that
to me I would really like to know
just seems like a weird thing for us to
just move on from that fast
but all right you know better than me
bud
okay let's go I'm ready get me out of
this
Creep Show
foreign
did I just miss the exit was that where
I was supposed to get up
I think I did right yeah okay
why it would want me to be able to go
back there though usually it blocks the
path when you progress
like I saw anything to do back that way
okay
can be for this one which looks pretty
busted
oh no are you planning to just pick me
up
no okay
we gotta deploy another
via cage
run past
[ __ ] man
I don't know how to attack you or I
would try
I don't love that it's making me rush
because taking
in the vibe of this game and like
getting a chance to survey things is the
thing I actually really like about it
[Music]
um
right now I'm just trying to not die
It's gotta be you somewhere
oh this is big
hmm
okay
big but not necessarily all necessary
there's no wall
something about that pausing as though
it is holding a ball like it doesn't
know any different the machine doesn't
it's very cool to look at
okay how to get ball
how to get bold
why did that scammy
well this is a bowl
oh God
I missed the creepy tail guy
he was way more chill
than weird head dude
yeah I do think a lot of the puzzles are
more just like finding something and
then hitting a
and seeing what it does
um
I feel like I prefer if it it was a
little more
complicated
um which some of them all they're not
old
absent of those kind of puzzles
like the first one from the prologue
where you had to
get the ball in the right place on the
wall or whatever definitely
definitely fit that bill oh no you can't
go this way anymore
okay
that's a shame
I ran here to avoid dying
okay
I honestly don't even know if what I'm
actually holding right now is a gun
and that's kind of part of the room
oh there it is oh there it is
probably should have learned how to kill
them I actually feel like that's a good
place to leave it almost exactly an hour
let me know if you want to see me play
more I don't doubt that I will I don't
think the game's very long
um so I I I'm definitely gonna finish it
I just whether I upload it or not and a
very big thank you to Kepler interactive
for providing me with a code so I was
able to play the game early I've been
looking forward to this game for a
really long time and the things that I
was looking forward to it for it
absolutely nails like the creepy
aesthetic very gross very grimy very
like wet it's it's something else um and
I'm really really impressed by those
aspects for sure so
yeah thanks for watching everybody I
will see y'all next time
[Music]